so tonight is the screening screening of
Anderson bench here in LA yes okay
real quickly you mentioned off-camera
about like telling a director the truth
about what you think of their work all
their blood sweat and tears they've
poured into something for several years
what's yours no pressure yeah just be
yourself but what do you think of that
telling someone the truth when you know
having both been on the other end of it
how hard it is to get something off the
ground
well you know when you're watching a
movie nobody who's watching a movie
really knows or cares how hard it is to
get something off the ground they don't
know how you shot it they don't know
that it was raining they don't know that
nobody showed up they didn't know that
the car had no gas they don't know any
of that so so you really can't
as much as filmmakers would like to say
you have no idea how hard this was it's
impossible that we did this and we did
it if the film sucks the film sucks if
the story doesn't if the story doesn't
engage you then it doesn't engage you
and it doesn't matter if you spend a
dollar or doesn't matter doesn't matter
if you're making driving miss daisy'
which didn't cost anything or the Lone
Ranger which costs two hundred million
dollars if you don't have a story
Driving Miss Daisy you could truly have
shot with a cell phone and a Zippo
lighter great story great acting
wonderfully engaging film Lone Ranger
not so much they had to have known they
were they were trying to polish a turd
they really they had to have known that
right I don't know but the whole
question is is that how do you feel
about someone telling you would you
rather someone be brutally honest or
would you rather than from their
perspective absolutely it's not the
question quit tap-dancing
I want them to be brutally honest yeah
not good you don't want him to polish a
turd no no tell me if you liked it or if
you I would what I like to do is I like
to watch people and see if they're
engaged in the movie if the
if they're laughing if they're crying if
the what do I say if the weight is on
the ball well if they're sitting is the
weight on their thighs are on their
tailbone that waits on the tailbone then
it's it's like okay mm-hmm but if you're
like this you're watching a movie like
this if you're leaning in
it means the movie is pulling you into
it regardless of what the story is right
yeah so if a person I guess I'm
tap-dancing if a person is at least
because I am a director I know how
people think right supposed to be
supposed to if people are watching a
movie like this and then when it's over
they say I didn't like that what that
means is they didn't like what it said
to them because it touched a part in
them that they're uncomfortable with
there's no way you can watch a movie
like this and not be engaged in it right
unless you're going I mean you're not
gonna sit for 90 minutes going when is
this thing ever gonna get better you're
not just not going to do that you're
gonna be back here like this you know be
looking at your watch I told the
director once there were there were
there were 10 things that you should
never explore in in a movie and the
movie I just saw had all 11 of them
how'd that work out I have never worked
for him that's what I didn't think so
that's good though right yeah directness
is always great he produced it I think
you know yeah I didn't I was offended by
it but see I was offended by it well
being offended and being judged to where
if something is good or not are two
different things I guess that's the
point we're circling back around to
right so when people ask how did you
like the film do you think they really
want to know or are they looking for
praise Wow
it depends on who's asking right do I
hear taps no okay it's that whole half
glass half-full half-empty thing it's
all about perspective and whose eco
you're feeding at the point in time
right and I think that it depends on if
it's a cast member or a director or a
producer or
all three from my perspective I want to
hear what the temperature of the film is
and whether they were engaged or not
engaged they keep their attention and
would this be something that they would
recommend to their film their friends so
that's you know from my perspective I
would never ask somebody how they like a
movie I'd say how did that how did that
make you feel what did that make you
feel when you were watching it because
to me because I'm the writer the writer
guy the director guy it's all about it's
all about feeling it's all about
engagement it's all about if a movie can
get under your skin
what's the high dollar word I know it
I'm gonna write like I said I'm a writer
visceral is it it was it a visceral
experience or were you just kind of was
in our case or in the case of Anderson
bench was it an accident you had to stop
and get out of your car to look at
closer or was it an accident you were
happy to just kind of drive by on the
freeway no I think it's a good analogy
okay yeah so has that take changed for
the two of you now that you're producing
films writing directing now that your
lives are taken a new course with that I
think what do you want to answer person
no you go right ahead I stepped up first
anyway
I just started in there real quick we're
gonna get my window of opportunity and
then shut up
so anyway open jump what I think is very
interesting on how John and I originally
met our intentions are very really yeah
okay got it
there anyway our intentions of an
approach to filmmaking except for the
physicality part of it because that was
a learning curve but our approach to the
type of cinema and stories that we want
to tell are very much the same and I
think that's where the likeness crossed
over and that's where we immediately got
on the same page
with one another mm-hmm is that we both
like to evoke emotions we like to I know
I that the from the films that I've done
before in the past taking a genre and
and shaking the genre and turning it
upside down and my lineage before that
was definitely more independent and
trying to acquiesce to the studio system
when I worked under Robert Evans
weighing at Paramount and Robert Evans
when he was at Paramount in 2002 was not
like what Robert Evans was in the 1970s
where filmmaking was definitely more of
the vein of or the approach of what
we're doing yeah there's a I don't think
either one of our perspectives have
really changed that much
I realize because of Alicia's production
savvy I realize you don't have to spend
a bunch of money you can you can spend
you can spend less money more wisely and
as long as you're telling a story as
long as the story is is on the page and
the characters are fleshed out they're
three-dimensional and and as long as
there's something worth telling then
there's no reason in the world to throw
a bunch of money at it if you don't have
to if you have to and I thought you had
to that meant meant that you had to
elicit the the blessings of several
people financial people studio people a
bunch of folks who who have their own
dream and have no business wallowing
around in yours or no desire this is the
what I've learned is they are no more
interested in my dream than I am in
theirs
so if through a relationship
professional relationship like what we
have you can you can get those words
that around the page fleshed out in
front of a camera and actually make a
movie for pennies on the dollar why in
the world wouldn't you do that so now we
don't have to go to a group of people to
have them bless what we want to do next
we do what we want to do next based on
our skin
based on the weather people who show up
in our lives based on people who show up
somebody will show up and and will think
you know that is the perfect so and so
let's make that movie next yep
well how freeing how great right how
great is that
and then when people when people see
them and you know this is we are we are
sitting on perhaps the eve of our
destruction who who have any idea what
we're gonna have people tonight see
anderson bench that have no idea what it
is they're gonna see a a very i think
different kind of love story and it is
representative of what we both like to
do to the norm it's a young love story
okay well that's like you said let's
let's let's push it let's turn it inside
out let's let's let's rip it in half
let's let's reach it let's reach down
the love stories throat and and invert
it violently which is more my take oddly
enough that's where my mind goes when we
do something about murder murder mystery
it's the same thing it's like what and
that's so refreshing to work with
someone who was as is as not saying
forward thinking because who knows what
that is but we are like-minded as far as
storytelling goes and we're not hinging
on whether or not we get a thumbs up or
a thumbs down we're still gonna make
movies that's not that right cuz we like
it it's just fine we enjoy it I did
country music for a long time and and
you are destined to fail as soon as you
are trying to make as soon as they a
group of talented creative people are
trying to make something that some other
group are going to like what you need to
make is a group of talented excited
people about whatever it is you're
making could be dental implants whatever
it is you're making you have to be
excited about it
you have to think you know this is I'd
this
fantastic this is what I like you cannot
I don't believe you can honestly make
something for a demographic that is not
you you can't make movies or towels or
soap that you would not use absolutely I
agree with that
you